I collect objects I collect branding
irons that were used to mark slaves as
property
I collect shackles for adults in
restraints for adults as well as
children
I collect lynching postcards yes they
depict lynchings they also depict the
massive crowds that attended these
lynchings and they are postcards they
were also used for correspondence
I collect pro-slavery books that portray
black people as criminals or his animals
without souls I brought you something
today this is a ship's branding iron it
was used to mark slaves or they were
actually were not slaves when they were
marked they were in Africa but they were
marked with an S to designate that they
were going to be slaves when they were
brought to the US and when they were
brought to Europe another object or
image that captured my imagination when
I was younger was a Klan rope growing up
in South Carolina I would see Ku Klux
Klan rallies occasionally actually more
than occasionally and those memories of
those events never really left my mind
and I didn't really do anything with
that imagery until 25 years later a few
years ago I started researching the Klan
the three distinct waves of the plan the
second one in particular the second wave
of the Klan had more than five million
active members which was five percent of
the population at the time which was
also the population of New York City at
the time the Klan Row Factory
in the Buckhead neighborhood of Georgia
was so busy it became a 24-hour factory
to keep up with orders they kept 20,000
robes on hand at all time to keep up
with the demand
as a collector of artifacts and as an
artist I really wanted a Klan robe to be
part of my collection because this
artifacts and objects tell stories but I
really couldn't find one that was really
good quality what is a black man to do
in America when he can't find the
quality Klan robe that he's looking for
so I had no other choice I decided I was
going to make the best quality Klan
robes in America these are not your
traditional Klan robes you would see at
any KKK rally
I used Kinte cloth I used camouflage
spandex burlap silks satins and
different patterns I make them for
different age groups I make them for
young kids as well as toddlers I even
made one for an infant after making so
many ropes I realized that the policies
the Klan had in place or wanted have in
place 100 years ago are in place today
we have segregated schools neighborhoods
workplaces and it's not the people
wearing hoods that are keeping these
policies in place my work is about the
long-term impact of slavery we're not
just dealing with the residue of
systemic racism it's the basis of every
single thing we do again we have
intentionally segregated neighborhoods
workplaces and schools we have voter
suppression we have disproportionate
representation of minorities and car
serated we have environmental racism we
have police brutality I brought you a
few things today
the stealth aspect of racism is part of
its power when you're discriminated
against you can't always prove you're
being discriminated against racism has
the power to hide and when it hides is
kept safe because it blends in
I created this robe to illustrate that
the basis of capitalism in America is
slavery slaves were the capital in
capitalism the first Grand Wizard in
1868 Nathan Bedford Forrest was a
Confederate soldier and a millionaire
slave trader the wealth that was created
from chattel slavery best slaves his
property would bobble the mind
cotton sales alone in 1860 equal 200
million dollars that would equal 5
billion dollars today a lot of that
wealth can be seen today through
generational wealth oh I forgot the
other crops as well you have indigo rice
and tobacco in 2015 I made one row of a
week for the entire year after making 75
ropes I had an epiphany had a
realization that white supremacy is
there but the biggest force of white
supremacy is not the KKK it's the
normalization of systemic racism there
was something else I realized the Rogues
had no more power over me at all but if
we as a people collectively look at
these objects branding irons shackles
ropes and realize that they are part of
our history we can find a way to where
they have no more power over us if we
look at systemic racism and acknowledge
that it's sewn into the very fabric of
who we are as a country then we can
actually do something about the
intentional segregation in our schools
neighborhoods and workplaces but then
and only then can we actually address
and confront this legacy of slavery and
dismantle this
ugly legacy of slavery thank you very
much
[Applause]